-How are you?
-I'm good.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
I do want to say something.
I know you're an Eagles fan.
-I am.
-And so this, thus, ended a year
of being able to say
you were the world champion.
Just Philadelphia Eagles.
-Only last night.
But I hope you enjoyed your run.
It was a fantastic run.
-It was great, yeah.
It happened in
my lifetime, so...
-Yeah, so I just
want to say, you know,
I hope you got
the full amount of joy from it.
-You're saying this like it's
never going to happen again.
-No, I think now
it's just going to be
just the --
It's the Patriots forever now.
-No. That's not -- that's not --
That's not nice.
-Ah, yeah.
I want to -- Obviously, we
mentioned it tonight.
You cover scandals
as they break, as well.
Does this Ralph Northam moment
seem any different
than what we've gotten
used to in politics?
-Yeah, it's crazy.
-Yeah.
-Like, really crazy.
Like, he's done everything wrong
every step of the way.
Forget the blackface thing,
which is obviously abhorrent,
and putting that on his yearbook
page and whatever happened,
but just -- This is like
crisis communications 101,
what not to do.
-Yeah.
-Like, he changed his story.
"It's me. It's not me."
He almost moonwalked.
-Yeah.
-His wife also -- the
"Inappropriate circumstances."
Like, obviously says that a lot,
I think, not just about
moonwalking.
-Yeah. I will give him
a little credit.
He knows to look to her,
you know?
-You know what?
I've seen the clip so many
times, and, this time,
I really keyed in on her face
when he talked about,
"You know, I won that
dance contest?"
So what?
What are you talking about?
You won --
Like, he's bragging.
-At the end of the day, he wants
to get that detail out, as well.
-"Just by the way, I won."
Did I mention --
Like, you're all mad about
the blackface, but I won."
-Yeah.
-"Did you not
understand that --"
-It's like he's saying,
"There were a lot of guys
in blackface there who
didn't come close to winning."
-No. Seriously.
-"Imagine how embarrassed
they are."
-And, by the way,
I was 15 in 1984,
so I remember people dressing up
as Michael Jackson for, like,
Halloween or whatever.
All you need is
the jacket and the glove.
-Yeah.
-That's it.
-Red jacket, white glove.
You're Michael Jackson.
-Right. It's not like you had
to dress up like Ralph Northam.
Nobody knows who
that would be in a costume.
-That would be difficult.
-So, there has been some --
Some of the Right have said
if this was
a Republican that did this,
the media would be howling
at a much louder volume
than they are here.
-Have we not been
howling loud enough?
-It seems like
pretty good howls.
-We've all been in full howl.
-Yeah.
-I would like to point out, this
is the least we have mentioned
the president in
"A Closer Look" in months.
And I have to say, also, like,
you were very conservative
in your estimation.
You said
"virtually every Democrat."
I don't think there is a current
Democratic elected officeholder
who has said
he should stay in office.
Like not one.
Like, you can find a Democrat
to support anything.
You can find a Democrat
who supports Maduro --
And Republicans,
too, on the other side.
But you can find a Democrat who
supports Maduro in Venezuela.
You can find a Democrat who
says we should talk to Assad.
You can find a Dem-- But
there's not one
who is supporting him on this.
I mean, it's really
unbelievable.
-And what do you think their war
room is like right now?
Because, obviously, you know,
he's made this decision
not to immediately resign.
Do you think the conversation
is going to eventually lead him,
you know, when he talks to
his staff and his advisers,
to walk away from this?
-I hadn't thought about
what his war room is like,
but that's an interesting --
That's an interesting question.
-I mean, I'm assuming they move
the table against the wall
so he can, like --
when he moonwalks, yeah.
-A lot of moonwalking.
-Yeah.
-Red jacket, collar up.
-It's tough to know
when he leaves office,
because the issue
with the moonwalk is --
it looks like you're
coming when you're going.
-It looks like
you're walking forwards
when you're actually
going backwards.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't know what kind of
war room it is,
but it doesn't seem like
there are a lot of generals.
I mean, it's --
I don't understand
the decisions being made.
-Yeah.
We have a
State of the Union tomorrow,
a week later
than we were expecting.
We were talking backstage.
You will obviously be
discussing it after the fact.
Now that we're sort of into a
conventional State of the Union,
are we going to learn anything?
Are we going to
glean anything from tomorrow?
-I mean, I think no matter what
kind of speech President Trump
gives tomorrow, he's going to
continue to govern and tweet
the way he's been
governing and tweeting.
I mean, I think we've -- I think
the pivoting --
There is no more talk
of pivoting...or moonwalking.
-No, no, no.
-He could give a very
unifying address tomorrow
and talk about the ways
the Democrats and Repub--
Somebody is
making better jokes up there.
All the ways the Democrats
and Republicans
can work together and
this and that.
And I think everybody
is like, "Okay, we know --
Tomorrow morning, you know
what's going to happen."
-Yeah. And we were saying
backstage,
I think the thing that I'm
looking forward to the most is
that Nancy Pelosi will be
sitting behind him,
and he knows that.
And I just think, in his head --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I predict a lot of him
looking back --
Anytime he gets a
standing ovation
from Republicans, looking back
at her and saying, like...
-I mean, she does seem to have
gotten into his head.
-Yeah.
-I mean, he doesn't
really know --
He hasn't come up with
a nickname.
-Yeah.
-He does seem to have
a grudging respect for her.
The Democrats
stayed unified during
the longest shutdown in
American history, didn't budge.
So I don't know that he's gonna
look, but he'll sense her.